yeah hello my name is John Berger I'm
from Beaufort mathcore located in lead
shipping Sweden we are responsible for
the development of the sister modular
and today I will present the new
features from April this year as well as
and mostly actually new features that
are coming later this year or beginning
next year
so passing on a bit bit of a Swedish
candy there for those of you that want
to taste it's which most of it is from
Sweden everything is born in Sweden some
of them are not produced in Sweden yeah
I think the one you had there is
finished actually
so in the 50s 60s something like that in
Sweden we decided to to introduce
something called loader scooters
Saturday candy the idea was to focus all
candy eating to one day a week to get
less consumption of candies right and
the consequence of course was that kids
started to demand candy every Saturday
and and continue to consume yes as mass
candy the other days so nowadays we are
the country that eats more most can
candy in the world so yeah and what does
that have to do with this presentation
I'll get back to that
my name is Jurgen I'm the CEO of all
from mathcore we develop system modular
which is one of all France products
today I'm going to focus on what we have
done during 2019 in April we launched
system over 12 now the last few weeks
we'll have launched free what we call
virtual labs and then actually since
last conference and until now we have
been working on 12.1 and beyond oh sorry
ok ok so that's the things I want to
cover and I have I would say I have
material for like five presentations in
my presentation here so we'll see what I
choose to present them out I will for
sure not present everything that said I
will focus mostly on what hasn't been
released yet I think that's what this
conference is sort of all about but yes
a quick summary first of system over 12
it was released
together with Mathematica 12 in April it
focus on three areas model creation
model exchange and model optimization
and for the sake of time I want to
through anything of that content instead
I would say invite you to come down to
the basement and we can present there
where we have more candy hopefully if
everything hasn't been consumed and also
go to the web page where you can see
quite a lot of information on what was
included so likewise the virtual labs
these will be covered in next talk by
Uncas my click and get down there so
these are we are trying to do as it
developed models or packages with models
in system owner together with material
that fits into different courses in
colleges and high schools and the idea
is to be able to cover sort of the
entire engineering curriculum and making
make teaching come more alive so people
can more easily set their equations into
con context but that will be presented
by by on kit later on so I will not
really go through that in detail so yeah
now when the can has gone all the way
through that we're back to the candy so
when you took some I don't know how
randomly shows what what it would take
some of them were sour other ones were
salty somewhere licorice sandwich sugar
so we have all sorts of candy in Sweden
and but they are nicely structured this
is from my grocery store back home meal
in shopping when I enter there is a wall
full of this the first thing I see but
this is not that wall this is at the
exit because there's another one there
and I only it can be basically where I'm
cycling so so I don't buy too much but
anyways
you have all these tests and some might
love the sort of let's say sugar loaded
candies that we have here someone will
love the sour candies that we have here
and then we have some liquorice over
there and so on or a combination of them
what we're working on on twelve one is
sort of like that we have a bunch of
different things that in a sense not
always you won't always see that they
fit with all all of them but you can
pick between those things for your
perfect package first thing synchronous
so we're adding a library for modeling
synchronous systems basically systems
that are clocked typical system model
works with with continuous systems I
throw a stone and want to see how that
travels from point A to point B but
every now and then for instance if you
have a control system that might be have
some sort of clocked system in it and so
on and then you want to be able to model
that too so we aren't reintroducing
support for that and I will show that
with an example here so let's go here an
opening in in the presenter mode of
system order that has been changed for
this release so we can we can focus only
on the model what we see here is a
mixing tank over here and we want to
control the level of the mixing tank so
we have the same mixing tank model here
it's the very same it's continuous
system in both cases but we can see that
it's in a sort of a box here that box is
a box that inverts the model so it
automatically makes the inverse of the
same model then inside this red box you
can see here on the left there's a
sample unit that will sort of is sampled
by clock could be sort of any a it can
be freak when they can you can clock
like in any combination you would like
and we have another sampler here
and here we have something called a hold
unit
so everything in in that red region is
within this sort of sampled region that
means that everything in here will be
will be treated as if it's if it's
discrete rather than continuous even
though the models are actually continues
so let's simulate that so I simulate
this and I can see an output here let me
zoom in like that yes for a bit we see
that two different signals we can zoom
in a bit more actually to get it even
clearer so the upper one there has some
dots on it and dashes that's the thing
synchronous signal so it only has values
actual at the dots well this one is a
continuous signal so it's represented
differently and all this is taking care
of autumn automatically as soon as you
add your your your sample and hold units
this will work in this case we have on
purpose made of a sort of a bad
controller in order to make it easy to
distinguish between the two two systems
in the presentation later on if you
download it there are more step-by-step
details on each of the examples with
more descriptions so you can run through
and understand a bit more so this is the
part of synchronous
create system model our people using
create anyone and using create system
model here is a few here so yeah so then
then I'll take a bit of time here so
what we have focus on for create system
our goal now is mostly on making it
complete when it comes to States based
models so now we can handle systems with
delays we can handle a fine state-space
models and non linear state-space models
we couldn't if not do before so if we
take the let's take the if a fine state
space model as an example so this is
taking from from the Mathematica
documentation actually the the example
in itself so you might have have seen
this we're not going to go through
they're sort of mathematical part of it
but we're generally we basically making
a model in Mathematica here and we can
plot the result so this is pure both
from language code code right to get
this sort of result here but suppose now
that you want to use this in the largest
system so you want to use it within
system or how do you do that well then
you'll use the create system model and
it says I will you spend here which is
up there it should be if I haven't
changed name it should should be because
I'm changing things yeah so it's this a
fine state space model that we want to
bring into system modeler and we will
give it this name here create system
model pendulum like that so now we're
creating that model and if I would go
over to system molar I can find it there
or I can do system modular get the text
representation of it here so we get sort
of we open here and we get the Metallica
code that was generated so this is the
system model representation of the same
model that this means that this can now
be used drag and drop as anything else
within system modeler to build a larger
sister
good user interface has been a lot of
things the user interface one of my
favorite things was sort of ready two
days before I left Sweden so means track
of time but four or five days ago and
that's a documentation generator so many
times you develop a model or a city
library and you want to have some
documentation online for others to read
it right you want to publish that but in
the models themself if we look at the
model like this one let's go and change
to the modular view so in the model
typically you do things like this we see
has no documentation but you might go in
and say start write something some
documentation for it right
typically this is what you do you add
pictures and so on and to make this look
nice okay so this is them built in in
the you have spent this effort to make
your library well documented but how do
you show this to others who don't have
the library or don't have the software
well now you can easily right click on
something like my new system new in
system of the library here right click
there and I say export as HTML so let's
do that then it's asking me if I how
which things do I want to link so this
is my presentation for today and I could
say ok I want to link to
Touma Delica files if I generate the
documentation for that I want to link to
model like a synchronous for instance
which we are using
so let's yeah let's say that I add
mallika synchronous and add links to
that so click OK
and now it starts to generate my
documentation generate those pages and I
can click this one here to get my
webpage so this is a complete web page
now with the documentation so this is
chrome which is my go-to browser and it
has all the documentation that I have
written in my in my package so for
instance if I go in here to new in 12 X
click there we get in back to the candy
which was the picture of hard for your
information and I see which packages
contains so I guess presented
synchronous we can go in and see their
synchronous what did I have as an
example there
well I had just one example automatic
discritization I can go in there see the
full documentation for it
I get which parameters it has but I can
also see which components it uses like
this so I can see that this and this is
automatically part of the components and
view this automatically just sort of
populated for you you don't have to do
anything it just happens so it has again
for instance has come from more delicate
blocks math gained and it has a whole
computer component here this one is
linked this one not because I clicked
when I clicked here I said which things
do I want to have linked so I said ok
let's let's link the things that goes to
motor local synchronous so then I can
actually click on hold and it takes me
to that page from mother like a
synchronous and I can understand this is
not a well it's looking on my machine
right now but it could be UK it's yeah
it's just it doesn't need much just HTML
pages so it's same here on my desktop so
these are the HTML files you just cope
with them wherever you want on a server
where you want to have it on your they
they I have generated that too and you
can generate that for yourself and and
then so you can generate for
library you have for the model like a
standard library for college thermal or
for anything and just push it and
publish it wherever you like nice right
good and there are a bunch of other
things like here's a short list of
things including model center we won't
go through that that will do a debugging
example now I'm really tight on time
okay I do part I will do the beginning
of this of this example and so many
times when you're developing new models
you do that in in the text mode in this
mode here so let's do this and it hasn't
always been that easy to understand when
you make a mistake what kind of mistake
have you actually done so let's do some
mistakes here I have started with the
model here and I'll check the model
let's do this so you can actually see
what I'm doing there you go right so
then it says new instance of a resistor
has this one here has an unknown
identifier V it doesn't recognize V
meaning I haven't declared V so I have
to do that so I can do that here and
that can immediately showing a single
error e that will be moved to Polaris
later on and it has actually a really
immediate see that I has the same
problem so I could do this add them so
now I've declared both those and I will
check again and it tells me okay this
works but it has two variables in one
equation which means that it's it's AM
bars we'll need as many variables as
equations to get it to simulate so that
could be for instance adding a simple
equation that would be a battery let's
say constant voltage and now we would
have something that works
however it wouldn't work to
plug-and-play this into another system
because it doesn't have any any
connections to it so you can't use it
within another system so you might want
to do that and so let's do that
let's say I want to then use this I go
to electrical analog interfaces and find
an interface I want to use for instance
there let's use a 1 port so I do this
I'll say extends one port I data typing
czar preferred drag-and-drop and then I
check this and suddenly it says element
B is duplicated but it's a zone so let
me click on what then it tells me ok so
we have a V here yeah that was the one
that I declared right but we also have
one here in the in the example that I
inherited from and then it's up to me to
remove one of those or make them equal
because I'm actually allowed to have it
twice as long as they are identical and
this example sort of and that's included
in the present download presentation
shows step by step until we get a fully
functional model so it's a very good way
to get exactly where you should fix and
what you should fix when making errors
fluid I know there's a bunch here
interest in fluid I will only sort of
show quickly the model here and invite
people to come downstairs and and
discuss it further for details but
basically we added a library we're
adding a library this is not sure it
well my 12-1 is sort of right there to
make it or not make it depending on when
where one will come but it makes it
possible to deal with multi-phase flows
in this case we we have a drum boiler
and let's see where are you
I talked with their er yeah so if you
want to understand what this I showed
this to James yeah yesterday and he
needed could you explain what this was
for me it's not my area but and that was
the first time you see so system model
right and I think that's sort of the
beauty of it that you can understand the
model if it's your discipline you can
understand it the first time you see it
well I I sort of can fake but now when
he's here I wouldn't try to fake it to
things before I cloud we're working on
cloud support it's the same issue that
the and and and now it's running on the
cloud I'm not running it here because I
haven't been able to set it up on my
computer so this is a web browser it's
the college thermal lab that Hank it
will show soon Ronnie
running there the big thing is the
sandboxing making as we handle compiled
C code and the user can sort of compile
anything they want you need to make it
safe so so they don't harm the systems
by with their models so that's what
we're working on and might make 12 one
or not it's sort of 50/50 yes that's
clear and as you see then bronze justice
would have been on the desktop last
thing in a very sort of full speed
presentation machine learning yet again
I won't go through all the details of it
but some the ball front language as in
you know has a lot of support for
machine learning as we're very strong
they're in many cases you might want to
combine this machine learning algorithm
with a with a system model to get sort
of something more complete for instance
you want to have a machine learning
learning algorithm as a controller so
this basically shows how let's do it a
couple of the steps you threaten to kick
me out good good
so yeah yes do the first step here so we
have I make some random input here that
I will use and then I have a system in
system model this one here where I say
run this system model simulate using
this input okay so I simulated with the
input and then I get some output right
so I get the input and output and then
this continues like I use we use here
system order then we organize the data
that we got from the output here we set
up in your neural network then we trade
a network just as which would have done
otherwise in in in the Wolfram language
nothing special only that I have sort of
hidden all the code to set it up here
and it's not because I don't understand
how the machine learning that would work
is just so you don't have to see
everything then this is is what will be
added create sister model perhaps a
little bit bigger as I give it the name
my net and call and use this network
that we created to as the name now that
as I didn't run it I will do this
instead I'll I'll prepare it and I'll
show that as the last thing we go here
modeler go down to my example package
new and sister mutlar machine learning
examples and let's take this one with
the cosine so we have this is our system
is system all in a normal system then we
we make some time delays signals we use
this time delay signals to sort of
forecast how we would expect the system
to behave
which is on the right-hand side is this
is our network that we developed in the
wall from language so we use this as a
drag-and-drop thing and then we can see
how well does this network predicts
manage to predict my output and we can
see it here that's sort of actually
pretty good at doing that and if I want
to see things just as a final thing of
user interface stuff
I can for instance take drag here put
two markers and I will get a bunch of
measurements for instance what's the
frequency sort of what's the time
between these two what's the frequency
what's the maximum minimum value and so
also I get some more information and
there I got stop thank you very much
[Applause]